brexit is now less than six weeks away
how do you rate the chances of Britain
leaving with a deal I had a meeting with
Thomas Johnson the prime minister this
was a rather positive meeting although
the British press was reporting it in
the other way we can we can have a deal
do you think we can get a deal I think
you think that the chances are more than
50/50 I don't know but I'm doing
everything to have deal because I don't
like the idea of no dealer because this
would have catastrophic consequences
it's better and for Britain and for the
European Union to have a an organised
deal is the EU ready for NATO for four
and No Deal yeah we are we are prepared
the no deal for at least one year
because in Britain ministers Prime
Minister saying okay is no deal there
will be no deal and we we are prepared
for that Britain is prepared as well the
UK by the way the UK has submitted some
written ideas have you received them
what did you ever see we have received
some documents yesterday night I had no
chance no opportunity to take them on
the meditation what I will do this
tonight do you think they are serious I
didn't see them because the center was
lately but I had the prime minister on
the phone and I do think that on that
basis things are possible what is it
that the UK government is suggesting
yeah but I haven't seen it then you've
spoken to questions I have spoken to
boys Johnson without knowing to contend
of the British proposals and so I'm not
able to speak of this proposal with the
highest authority because I didn't see
you must know the direction no I don't
know the direction III was asking the
Prime Minister when he was there in
Luxembourg the other day to make
concrete proposals as far as the
so-called alternative arrangements are
concerned allowing US and Britain to
achieve the main objectives of the
backstop I don't have a neurotic as a
relation to the back ship that's it the
base table but if the results are there
I don't care about the instrument so the
back sock okay
if the objectives in that if the
objectives are met all of them then we
don't need the best of it because
anywhere backstop was a guarantee
instrument not a name by itself what
we're here in the UK
is that one of the ideas is for Northern
Ireland to follow EU rules on food and
agriculture and then for other checks to
be done away from the border do you
think that's a basis of a deal is a
basis you think that's the starting
point starting under over there are
other problems EC
when it comes to the internal markets
and internal market has to be preserved
in its entirety there are many problems
we have it was not only those who
eventually and Geopetrol agreement could
be reopened no it will not be reopened
because I was told by the former Prime
Minister my good friend Tara Mae that
this is the only deal possible
it's the only deal possible and that's
the reason why I'm saying that the
backstop or not backstop if the
alternative arrangements which can be
envisaged serving the same objectives
then it can be done but if I accepted a
withdrawal agreement is a piece of paper
now it was a treaty I don't like this
way the British have to describe what we
agreed upon as a deal
what does that mean it was a treaty we
concluded the treaty but it was rejected
three times my Parliament right it went
past and we we have Westminster which is
apartment I deeply respect them this
part but of course has to agree and we
had European Parliament don't forget
that with the Parliament on the
continent to which has to agree it's not
only to up to Westminster to agree after
having had an agreement by Westminster
we need the European Parliament I don't
understand if the withdrawal agreement
has been rejected three times by
Westminster and you are saying that it
won't be reopened how there can be a
deal yeah this is a good question for
Westminster said the EU is not moving me
I was explaining again and again that if
the alternative arrangements allow us to
achieve the same goals then we don't
need the backstop but we have to save
the entirety of the internal market we
have to make sure that there will be no
haps and physical border in between the
two parts of the Irish Island and things
have to be done in on an a level playing
field
if these three objectives are met by the
alternative arrangements then we don't
need the backs of the backstop was
another an instrument having been put in
place for whatever will happen no it was
put in place in order to preserve the
rights of the internal market and of the
island of Ireland how do you think the
EU would feel about another extension
that's not our problem the Prime
Minister was very outspoken by saying
that he would not ask for an extension
so this is a theoretical question and he
repeated to me several times
that he will not ask a further extension
so why should I reflect on that if the
Prime Minister saying that they will not
do that and do you think there is a
chance that brexit might not happen
that's not my scenario I am convinced
that the brexit will happen you think
it's going to happen I think so and I
want to just look for a minute of what
happens if Britain leaves without a deal
would there be a border between Island
Northern Ireland and the Republic yes
there would be a border yes and and what
would that mean does that mean
infrastructure at the border but I will
not step by myself I mean that I'm not
an architect of new border stations the
British have to tell us exactly the
architectural nature of this bother I
don't like that border because after the
with Friday Friday Agreement this Friday
agreement has to be respected in all its
parts the situation in Ireland has
improved we should not play with this
yeah as you say the history of that
border we all know the history sometimes
I have the impression that some people
are forgetting about history like
history will be back immediately hey do
you mean some members of the British
Parliament are not criticizing them I
have to Isis respect possible for
Westminster because it's the mother of
the parliaments all they're not being in
session the UK government says that it
won't put up a border even if there
isn't it yeah so the EU will insist on a
border we have to make sure that the
interests of the European Union under
the internal market will be preserved a
an animal
entering Northern Ireland and we've all
polar control can enter without any kind
of control European Union via the
southern part of the Irish Island this
will not happen we have to preserve the
health and the safety of I understand
the importance of the single market the
internal market but to put up a border
is something that many people would be
incredibly worried about given the
history the deaths in that border I mean
it's not something the EU would be
responsible for do you is in no way
responsible for any kind of consequences
intact but the back seat does a British
decision a sovereign decision we are
respecting but don't try a cubed to
charge the European Union with
responsibility European Union is not
leaving the United Kingdom United
Kingdom is leaving European oooh so who
is responsible do you not even because
we did not invent the brexit
we were never pleading in favor of and
he kind of breaks it
that's a British decision and so it has
to be dealt with in that way do you how
David Cameron responsible he called the
referendum he was not the only one but
he's responsible for that he's a good
friend of mine by the way but and we
agreed a deal back in 2016 I think
between David and ourselves but this
deal was never explained to the wit
Republic never what about Jeremy Corbyn
what do you make of Labor's position he
said that he may try and negotiate a
deal if he was Prime Minister put it to
a second referendum and then maybe not
even campaign for it
that's a British and in a British
question I'm not interfering this non
debate between you two
okay and now to get back to the EU and
you clearly put responsibility to the UK
and this week though the prime minister
of Luxembourg held a press conference
and next to an empty podium where Boris
Johnson was supposed to be is that
helpful I don't know if this is helpful
I rather consider that this was not very
helpful but it is this
vision is my successor so I will not
comment on this behavior but I myself I
had a good meeting with Boris Johnson
polite friendly positive in many aspects
and I like the conversation I had with
the Prime Minister it was not a meeting
between two enemies for the meeting
between friends because some reports say
then actually at that meeting you later
said that it was the first time you
think he understood the single market
yeah I was reading that in the FT I
think yes that's right that's wrong so
you don't think the he misunderstood the
community and just anyway explaining
some dimensions of the internal market
but I did not have the impression that
he was discovering this while listening
just to get back to my question only
locks and by Prime Minister that the
reason that I asked it is because for
many people in Britain it really sums up
why they have an issue with the EU what
they don't like about the EU what is
perceived as an arrogant treatment at
the United Kingdom I don't know if this
was arrogant it was not necessary and I
do think that is the feeling you are
describing existed even before the visit
of boys Johnson to Luxembourg and
actually for some people you are the
face of what they have a problem with it
with the EU but they see you as the
Brussels very much unaccountable that's
a typical British life what I am
electrified but I do European Parliament
and what is that I don't - does it make
you angry in Westminster the European
Parliament was voting on me and was
voting on the Commission I was a prime
minister for 19 years I have three or
four other prime ministers in my team I
have so many the former ministers of
Foreign Affairs or defence everyone the
part of British Commissioner has been
elected
someone somewhere someday so stop this
nonsense this Faraj
nonsense does it make you angry no no
but I'm no longer in a mood to listen to
this stories that we are unelected
putschists
um reasonable guys we are there where we
are because people put us there you
tirelessly Commission president comes to
an end at the 31st of October the same
day as Brett said do you know that
sentiment of yeah yeah do you think that
people have more or less face in the
European Parliament and in the EU now
believer in opinion polls I don't like
all those my results in your opinion
polls were always even better than my
election results in Luxembourg according
to the last opinion poll I have approval
rate of 90 percent so they can't be
right the last opinion polls in all the
countries apart Britain are showing that
the citizens have become after brexit
stronger believers in the European Union
than before the approval rate of the
European Union and of the institution's
is higher than it was before
brexit which is quite astonishing is it
just on as you know people have seen
what can happen if a country decide is
to live and what I wanted to tell the
duty problem and your audience is that I
have no sense of revenge I will always
admire a bit because the place this
great nation has in Europe will not
disappear with we bracket the European
continent I was a lot to Brit what is it
that you like about Britain what I do
like yeah you know I was born after the
second world was visibly worth
but in my country the small country
accent twist this remaining feeling that
Britain did resist more than others
before others and after others to the
Nazi regime the Germans wanted to impose
on the rest of Europe luxembourg was
invaded like the netherlands and like
belgium on the 10th may 40 and the only
ones who immediately took our defense
not only by lip service but by paying
lip service but but doing things which
had to be done with the british and so
wax it or not wax it I will always love
with I'm keeper host apps the European
Parliament spoke at Lib Dem conference
in the United Kingdom and he said the
world of tomorrow is a world of empires
in which we European a new British can
only defend your interests your way of
life by doing it together in a European
framework do you think it's a world of
vampires no but I don't like these
expression empires I don't know what it
means it's sounds rather aggressive
military but the truth is that as
European countries given the new
competitors we have worldwide European
countries have to stick together you
should not forget that at the beginning
of the 20th century 25% of the world
population was European no 7 by the end
of the century 4 percent out of 10
billions the European continent is
anyway the smallest Europeans don't know
it but we are very small continent very
complicated one has been as we know and
our relative economic weight is
disappearing we we have now a share of
the
global GDP of 25 percent in 20 years
from now it will be 15 16 is this the
moment to separate or is this the moment
to stand together that's the reason why
I'm unhappy about brexit that's the
reason why I do want to have an as close
relationship as possible with this poor
nation called United Kingdom
I am I used to say there were only two
big states in Europe the Grand Duchy of
Luxembourg and Wed quit and just finally
well I've got you you were talking
before about new or unfair portrayal of
you in the newspapers in Britain and
sometimes your paper traders a bit of a
bump over the sort of person who ruffles
women's hair at press conferences oh
yeah is that what you're like no that's
what I'm doing
but I was very much surprised when I saw
this story of the head of my deputy
chief protocol it was the wind it was
not me
thank you very much thank you